sticky one that's a good question
someone that get
[Music]
a fruit someone awaits you think so yeah
i believe so because i feel like if
you're able
kind of does depend on the vibe but if
you're able to just like
slang it out so soon so quickly he might
not take you as seriously as someone
that's like more patient and would get
to know him
and kind of understand him better really
yeah let's hear from the guys i disagree
totally okay yeah you'd rather have
someone that would just no no
you don't have to slang it out no but
that was but no but it's like
there's a difference between that let's
say you make someone wait for a month
but whilst well making me wait for a
month let's say i may just like lose
interest in but you're making moves
towards like but she's just holding off
i'm just saying that as
not me but just like people
people they might like
lose interest in that because is that
all that like chasing and stuff like
that bro not everyone wants to do the
chasing stuff for so long but i mean you
can you chase say you chase you get it
what now yeah imagine you chase for
imagine chase for a month and it's dead
bro
[Applause]
okay and then what if you chase for a
month and it's good then you're chilling
but we could have been good
the next day um
we could be like cool maybe we're not
you know this is what 29 days so it's
basically it's based on the 90-day rule
i don't know that's a bit of a sticky
one see because
on one hand i feel like guys do value
some sort of purity right and it's
biologically wired so it they can't
really get rid of it but any guy like
that finds out his girls slept with a
hundred people probably wants to throw
up
yeah yeah
okay
i'll get him no i'll never wife you if
you have hundred bodies
it has to you have to
you know i mean run a little bit and
you know flex a little bit but you can't
just you know because then you think our
next man could have had it easy like
that yeah so
it's just i guess there is a balance in
it because then you could go on a lit
first date and you guys could have sex
and then it could even be even better
but because you know the person you guys
are on the same vibe you kind of can
move forward from that but whereas like
do you know what i mean slang it out and
then you're done with that
yeah i feel like i feel like there is a
balance like
wait but don't slang out too early to
get it yeah but if you're gonna make
them wait don't make them wait too long
that just depends on who the guy is
there's some guys i don't mind they can
wait till marriage there's some guys
right but bro let's be rude there are
actually you're out there
there aren't guys
[Laughter]
now but there are actually some guys
that can wait would want to wait but
that just depends on them
yeah that's the thing that it just has
to be
i feel like that just has to be a
balance between dinner
are you waiting until you're married
okay
i thought you you said you said right
there
she said no
i like to have a little bit of fun you
know what i mean
someone in the comments it says it's not
biologically wired it is biologically
wired because over in history men have
to ensure paternity
so and the reason men prefer like a
lower body count is because historically
they had to ensure paternity
so um they had to make sure that they
weren't passing on resources to a kid
that wasn't theirs
because birth control changed the game
but that wasn't around historically and
even now there are some studies that say
up to like 20 percent of men are raising
a kid that's not theirs
it's crazy so would you guys do that
he's a kid that's not mine yeah
you'll fall in love with it yeah that's
hard it depends on what that sort of
situation with the goal like if i'm with
that's not even just that it's not even
just if you're with them
if you've been with her
think about it think about it think
about it so so she told me she's
pregnant like two months pregnant
so for that seven months before the
baby's born
you've
grown to like adapt to like becoming a
man and then
you could be with a kid like four months
five months could be the first day you
love that baby
like find out that's not yours
your love for the baby is not going to
like change it's going to change for the
girl you're going to hate the girl yeah
resentment every time you look at the
baby you could just be like damn
like
i can't control it have you not seen
them them like judge shows where they're
having like them like they have the test
or you're the father you're not the [ __ ]
and you see that like
the men just break down in tears
it hurts it bro
if she's had the kid already
and
would you guys do it then
yeah you have to collect for the ride i
mean the kid has to be young though if
you're 15 in that corner
oh my gosh
you know what's crazy about that like
the perception will probably change like
you know if you're like 40 50 unless
you're single bro a lot of women that
you're gonna come
in contact with may have a kid bro and
they're gonna be 15 16 17 18
then it will change bro i mean yeah when
i get to that point it would change 15
hours loose bro we're like 20.
come on imagine i'm trying to imagine
i'm trying to say something you're not
my dad oh
no
oh
no but it's like when they're younger
yeah it'll be less it'll be a less
likely thing that they will say that
because yeah because they're young in it
that's probably
the first exactly
but they know that there's a day now
someone's coming to now come like take
over and then you've raised your voice
at me like oh you're my dad no you are
you bro
i can't like that [ __ ] will burn bro
like i'll burn so wait would you guys
date a single mom
so you you sounds like you wouldn't
whoa
oh that hold on don't do that
i would
it depends though
really why
that's terrible you like what you like
words you like what you like
you're gonna be attracted to her if she
thought she has a kid but your
attraction for us still there
like you have to do the whole packaging
she eventually told you after like two
months talking like intense talking
energy i'm saying like your combo every
day what but okay you guys like
are you that desperate
you could date a girl without kids why
on earth would you date a girl with a
kid
because because that's that one you're
raising you're putting your time
attention and resources into another
man's kid and she could break it off
with you tomorrow you put all this time
attention and resources and raising
someone else's kid you get nothing you
have no rights all the resources are
worthwhile i mean
yeah it's just i mean i'm not paying
child support
if you live life like that you're not
going to do anything yeah because you
can say that about the girl as a single
like i mean she doesn't have a kid as
well you put all your time and results
into that girl for her to bring you off
and cut yeah bro
child don't know a child
you're getting married with no kids
when you meet a girl yeah it's it's not
just her attraction is the whole package
what about if there's like baby daddy
drama yeah like i would oh my gosh i
have brothers if they brought home a
girl with a kid i would tell them to him
to dump her
immediately
and then after a bit when you feel like
yeah it'd be a lot harder to just leave
by the way i got a baby dad already
it's gonna be harder but like at the
start
you shine and there's a lot of people
that do it think about how these stories
are on people that like bring up kids
that's not even theirs bro and they have
a happy family
come on man obviously there's some that
don't yeah but that's with everything
but like why would you want to like take
that extra baggage like that's just
baggage because you have to deal with
the axe yeah you don't look at baggage
if the girl
you know what's interesting when i'm
like talking to a guy and he tells me he
would date a single mom i like like him
less
because i'm like like i to me your
discernment is off oh what do you think
that they're just picking
more well it's like it's like why would
you if like it's like almost desperate
and i'm not trying to be mean so sorry
but like but like because i'm like do
you not have any other like are you that
desperate you would date a single
mom what does that how does that show
you desperation
because you could like because it's like
you act like there's even if you're
talking to a girl for a month it's only
been a month that's better than raising
someone else's kid for the rest of your
life
and it's one thing like happiness like
i think kids with people with kids
should date each other
i didn't i've been in a situation where
dude didn't tell me he had kids i was
out cooked no next